يتابع العالم بقلق تداعيات قرار حظر حركه
طالبان التعليم الجامعي للنساء في
افغانستان الى اجل غير مسمى وبالرغم من
ردود الفعل الدوليه المتواليه التي
استنكرت هذه الخطوه معتبره اياها تضييقا
على حريه النساء ومنعا لحقهن الاساسي في
التعليم وازدياد الضغوط المطالبه بالتراجع
عنه الا ان هناك ايادي تصفق مؤيده لهذا
القمع وتطل بين الف ليله والاخرى لتشعل
فتيل التشدد وتؤجج الصراع الازليه بين
المعتدلين والمتشددين قرروا طالبان بحظر
تعليم النساء لم يحظى بتاييد اي مؤسسه
دينيه او جهه دوليه كونه اعتبر انتهاكا
صريحا للقيم الانسانيه والدوليه
هيئه كبار العلماء السعوديه دعا الطالبان
الى التراجع عن قرارها بمنع الطالبات من
التعليم الجامعي لافته الى اهميه الاستماع
الى ما يقضي به الدين الاسلامي من تمكين
المراه من التعلم اما الازهر فقد عبر عن
كون القرار يشكل صدمه لانتهاكه مبادئ
الاسلام وتناقضه مع الشريعه الاسلاميه
التي تدعو لطلب العلم للنساء والرجال على
حد سواء الامين العام لرابطه العالم
الاسلامي ورئيس هيئه العلماء المسلمين
الدكتور محمد العيسى اكد بان هذا القرار
ام مخالف لاجماع علماء الامه الاسلاميه
بمختلف مذاهبهم وطوائفهم داعيا طالبان الى
التراجع عنه وماربا عن تضامنه التام مع
الفتيات والنساء الافغانيات في هذه القضيه
المرتبطه بشكل مباشر بمستقبل المراه في
افغانستان
رنده الشيخ العربيه